The country of yoga…
The country of Gandhi and non-violence…
The country where you travel to grow spiritually…
…is the very same country where the far
right wing has won the elections… again!
If you think ultranationalism is a Western
thing, you’d better think again.
Believe me, by the end of this video, Donald
Trump will look like a liberal hippy to you.
India is the World’s biggest democracy.
Yes, you heard that right.
In this past election, more than 600 million
people cast their vote: this is twice as much
as the whole US population.
Nevertheless, I bet many of you couldn’t
even name their Prime Minister.
Oh yes!
It doesn’t matter if India the second most
populated country on the planet or the World’s
largest democracy… the media couldn’t
care less about this country.
And this is why here, at VisualPolitik, we’re
obliged to tell you about this man you see
on the screen: NARENDRA MODI, the man who
has just been re-elected as the Indian Prime
Minister.
Many of you might think that looking this
peaceful, being vegetarian and practicing
yoga, Modi is a spiritual politician who loves
peace and human rights, right?
Well… the opposite is true.
Next to Narendra Modi, Donald Trump looks
like Bono from U2.
Have you
ever heard about India’s sacred cows?
So yes, they are real.
And believe me when I say that this is much
more than just a funny thing from Hinduism.
The cow Belt is a Group of Indian states where
religion plays a major role in society.
Within these regions, we have the cow vigilantes.
Theoretically, the cow vigilantes’s role
is to protect these animals.
But, in many cases, they’ve formed into
violent tribes that attack minorities, mainly
Muslims.
According to a Human Rights Watch report,
in the last 5 years they have killed more
than 44 people just because they were eating
beef.
In other words, you can find fanatics in any
religion, including Hinduism.
But if India is the World’s largest democracy,
their elections are also the World’s longest.
In most democratic countries, voting lasts
for one or two days, right?
Not in India!
Here they need 7 weeks to cast their votes.
Why?
Because every state holds elections on different
days.
And remember, we’re talking about 900 million
possible voters.
Along with the long elections, the campaign
has been a hell of a show.
From the tension with Pakistan to a Bollywood
movie.
Oh yes, you heard that right.
If spots weren’t enough, Narendra Modi made
his own Bollywood biopic…
PM Narendra Modi movie review: An unabashed
hagiography
With such a huge electoral campaign, Modi
has been reelected in a landslide victory.
Basically, his party has 65% of the seats
in the parliament.
This is a similar majority to that of Putin
in Russia or Viktor Orban in Hungary.
And the opposition parties in India are too
small to effectively block his policies.
So Today’s question is…
Why has India decided to give even more support
to the far right?
Can we really say this country is radicalizing?
And what kind of consequences will this have
for the rest of the World?
Today we are going to answer to all of these
questions but, before we do, let’s take
a look back at the history.
MODYWOOD
Mahatma Gandhi is more than the founding father
of modern-day India.
He is a universal icon.
His goal was that, once India became independent,
both Hindus and Muslims could coexist peacefully.
Although India is a Hindu majority country,
they also have a Muslim minority.
Well… it’s not even fair to say a minority:
we’re talking about more than 200 million
people who believe in Muhammad’s teachings.
That said, both Gandhi and Modi were born
in the same state.
And… this is where the similarities between
these two end.
Modi was born into a humble family and, since
he was a child, he was fascinated by politics.
So where did he go?
To the Association of National Volunteers,
also known as the SHANG family.
This is a radical Hindu organization with
a clear target in mind: Muslims are the enemy.
To give you a better understanding, the man
who shot Gandhi was affiliated with this organization.
And, yes, he killed Gandhi because of his
goal of making Hindus and Muslims coexist
peacefully.
So well, the Shang family formed the basis
of Narendra Modi’s political party: the
BHARATIYA JANATA PARTY, also known as the
BJP.
And as you can imagine, the ideology of this
party is far from centrist.
Nevertheless it soon became one of the biggest
political groups in India.
Here is where Modi kickstarted his political
career.
In 2001, he became the Chief Minister of the
state of GUJARAT.
And this is how his legend started.
Basically, Modi combined the BJP’s radical
narrative with a taste for pragmatic economics.
On the radical side, he even lost the visa
to travel to America or the European Union.
Why?
Well, because he allowed Hindu radicals to
harass Muslims at ease.
In the year 2002 they killed more than 1000
Muslims.
Modi’s administration was accused of handing
the radicals a list of all the properties
owned by Muslims.
On the other hand, Modi had his bright side
in economics.
He privatized several state owned enterprises,
he created industrial parks and removed a
lot of red tape, which is a persistent problem
all across India.
In very few years, GUJARAT was growing at
a 10% rate year after year.
Everybody saw Modi as a model for the rest
of the country.
So what was the next step then?
Of course, that would be ruling the entire
country.
In 2014, Modi became India’s Prime Minister.
His program included ending a lot of bureaucracy,
modernizing the country and improving the
country’s relationship with America.
Don’t forget that India used to be blacklisted
by the White House because of their nuclear
program.
So Modi did a great job getting closer to
Washington.
Yes, you heard that right: he went from not
having a visa to enter the States to becoming
Obama’s personal friend.
Don’t believe me?
Well… just check this out!
Obama writes profile for Modi in Time's most
influential list
Yes, you heard that right.
Barack Obama himself became besties with Modi
despite them having opposite ideologies.
And you might wonder… how is this even possible?
Basically, everybody was expecting India’s
economy to boom just like China’s had.
And Modi seemed to be the man for the job.
OK, OK, he might not be the biggest human
rights fan but… this is international politics
and we’ve seen worse.
But now the question is… did Modi really
pull India out of poverty?
What has he done during his time in office?
Let’s have a look, shall we?
THE HINDU TRUMP
Imagine if I said ‘Gandhi’s assassin was
a patriot’.
You might think this isn’t the best thing
to say during an electoral campaign in India,
right?
Butthis is what PRAGYA THAKUR said before
the elections.
PRAGYA THAKUR is a politician from the BJP.
And yes, she has won the elections in her
district just like Modi did.
And if this isn’t brutal enough for you,
look at this quote from AMIT SHAH, the chairman
of the party.
Amit Shah vows to throw illegal immigrants
into Bay of Bengal
I told you!
At the end of this video, you’ll think Donald
Trump’s a Hollywood liberal.
And wait because you haven’t seen anything
yet.
Now you might wonder… how is it possible
that, with such a radical agenda, Modi and
his party had such a landslide victory?
The answer lies in one word: ECONOMICS.
In this regard, Modi reminds us of Erdogan,
the Turkish president.
Both are religious extremists, both had good
relationships with America and both bragged
about economics at some point.
Oh, wait a minute!
What did you say?
You don’t know anything about Erdogan?
Well we talk about him in this video.
And don’t forget that if you want to discover
what happens around the World, you should
subscribe to VisualPolitik and hit that bell
button so you won’t miss any posts.
And hitting the bell button is really important
because it’ll allow you to get a notification
on your mobile phone anytime we publish a
new video.
Which we do several times a week.
So if you don’t wanna miss those, you know
what to do!
But let’s get back to our story.
Under Modi’s government, the Indian economy
kept growing at a 7% rate.
His administration managed to balance the
accounts by creating new taxes like VAT.
And this man has crafted himself an image
of a humble, hard working and business friendly
politician.
But, as we said before, the radical influence
has been present during his entire administration.
Basically, he’s given the Shang family the
keys to the government.
Today, the group controls the police, army
and the courts.
But that’s not all.
They control the biggest private school in
the country.
This means that 5 million children are educated
every day alongside their extremist principles.
And if the Shang family isn’t radical enough
for you, there are other organizations that
make headlines like this one.
Bajrang Dal activists beat up Muslim boy for
going shopping with Hindu girl
As you can see, the advance of Hindu radicalism
is becoming more and more worrying.
And I say Hindu radicalism because Modi’s
core ideology goes way beyond simple nationalism.
For example, his government has offered Indian
nationality to a lot of immigrants from Bangladesh,
Afghanistan or even Pakistan.
They just have to meet one condition: not
being Muslim.
So yes, BJP’s radicalism is a religious
one.
They just want India to only have Hinduism,
Buddhism or other small local religions.
And you might wonder… so what’s wrong
with that?
It’s their country and those are their religions,
right?
Well, remember that India still has more than
200 million Muslims.
They represent 14% of the entire population.
And believe me, their lives are not easy.
Why?
Well… let’s go back to the sacred cows.
Before Modi became Prime Minister, cows were
sacred until the moment they weren’t productive
anymore.
Then, authorities let them get slaughtered
so their meat could be eaten.
Usually, those slaughterhouses were owned
by Muslims.
And Muslims were the ones who ate the beef
too.
Under the BJP’s rule, many states have banned
beef consumption.
And the government has spent almost 90 million
dollars building cow shelters, also known
as GOSHALAS.
Inside of these shelters, cows are protected
under Hindu religious principles and they
promote vegetarianism.
Of course, all these measures are a direct
attack on the Muslim community.
Many Muslim families lived off of the production
of cow meat and now they’ve lost their livelihoods.
But to most of the radical groups, this is
not enough.
So in Today’s India, it’s easy to find
news like this.
Cow Vigilantes in India Killed at Least 44
People, Report Finds / About 280 people injured
in more than 100 attacks over 3 years
I told you before, you can find fanatics in
any religion…
But, OK, you might be wondering now… and
what about the economics?
Can we really say Modi was successful in this
regard?
The truth is also pretty disappointing.
Let’s have a look.
SMOKESCREENS
January 30th is The School Day of Non-violence
and Peace in observance of the day Gandhi
was assassinated.
At this moment in the video, you already know
that Gandhi and Modi couldn’t be more different.
If Gandhi was a peace icon, Modi is a total
pyromaniac.
Yes, it is true, India is still growing.
But we shouldn’t give credit to Modi for
this.
In fact, India started growing decades ago.
And so has its population.
What doesn’t grow is the job market.
Especially among the youth.
Young unemployment is at a record high.
And Modi’s promise to create 10 million
jobs is still just a promise.
Also farmers are angry.
Modi increased food imports to make prices
cheaper.
This is great for the cities but not for the
countryside.
Even if this liberalization was good in the
long term, it made Modi lose a lot of votes
in the rural areas.
And the same goes for his fight against the
shadow economy.
This is perhaps his biggest failure.
Overnight, Government retired 80% of Indian
currency from circulation.
They wanted to force everyone to use credit
cards and bank transfers instead of cash.
This way they couldn’t evade taxes.
The problem?
Not everyone has a bank account in India.
And financial institutions were not well prepared
for this.
So all of a sudden you had hundreds of people
going to the bank offices, trying to open
an account, and the bankers didn’t even
know what to do.
And who suffered the most?
Of course, the poorest people.
Those who had small businesses like a hair
salon, a street fruit shop or any other small
business had lots of trouble making ends meet.
All of this explains why at the beginning
of 2019, polls looked really bad for Modi.
Of course, he would still win the elections
but he would lose the absolute majority and
he would have to form coalitions with other
parties.
So what does an extremist politician do when
he wants to rise in the polls?
Well… the same thing Erdogan did: same old
protectionism.
India Curbs Power of Amazon and Walmart to
Sell Products Online
But, as we said before, Modi is a total pyromaniac
and he knows how to create smokescreens.
This is why, in order to raise national pride,
tensions with Pakistan, their die hard enemy,
are a great thing.
Under Modi, India performed their first airstrike
against Pakistani territory in 40 years.
This was their response to the Kashmir terrorist
attack.
Fortunately, this conflict hasn’t become
a nuclear war.
But it has been a great help for Modi in the
elections.
As we said, in 2019, polls said Modi wouldn’t
have the absolute majority.
Now, 6 months after that, Modi has made a
huge victory.
Remember the figure: his party has 65% of
the seats in the parliament.
So now the question goes to you…
do you think Modi is playing with fire, using
this ultra nationalist strategy?
Can Modi get India out of poverty?
Is Gandhi’s legacy lost in this country?
Please leave your answer in the comment section
below.
Also don’t forget to visit our friends from
RECONSIDER MEDIA.COM, the podcast that provided
the vocals in this video that were not mine.
And remember that we publish brand new videos
every week so subscribe to this channel and
hit the bell button so you won’t miss any
posts.
If you liked this video, give us a thumbs
up and, as always, I’ll see you next time.